[APPLAUSE]
KATY PRATT: Thanks, and hello.
CLAYTON PRATT: Hello.
KATY PRATT: So I'm
Katy Pratt, and this
is my husband, Clayton.
CLAYTON PRATT: I'm a
third-year medical student
at the University of Michigan.
KATY PRATT: And I
am a Googler, here.
I have been at Google for in
total, three and a half years,
but did leave for a
year, and then came back.
And work on gTech,
supporting Google Analytics.
CLAYTON PRATT: Many of you
probably have recognized Katy,
she works here.
If you recognize me, it might
be because you've recently
seen me on one of
your featured Learning
on the Loo advertisements--
[LAUGHTER]
--in the stalls at Google.
I didn't actually know Learning
on the Loo was a thing.
Over at the hospital,
bathroom stalls
are used for urine
samples, not advertising.
But what do we know?
While you guys are busy hanging
out and pinging each other,
we still send alphanumeric
pages and then run
across the hospital
looking for a phone
to get back to each other.
[LAUGHTER]
On July 1st, 2014, Katy
and I packed up our house,
and put three or four outfits,
our camping and bicycle repair
equipment, a MacBook
Air, and two smartphones
in these four yellow panniers,
a frame bag, and this duffel bag
with all of our
camping equipment.
And we flew to Heathrow
International Airport,
in London, England.
Our flight landed at
6:45 AM, and wanting
to make the trip as difficult
and as rigorous as possible,
we assembled our bicycle in
the fourth level parking lot
at the airport.
And six hours
later, around noon,
after Katy went and found a
piece that we actually forgot,
we hopped on our bike.
We started in London,
and we went north.
First to Edinburgh, and then
across Europe to Istanbul.
We ran into some problems
that we will talk about.
We spent two months
in Nepal and India.
And then three months
in Southeast Asia,
before two weeks in Utah,
completing our 10,000
kilometer, 28 country, 280
day across the world trip.
It was, by far, the
best trip of our lives.
But, to be clear, it wasn't
the best trip of our life
because we went to
Thailand and sat on a beach
for a year and sipped
mango smoothies.
We only did that for two weeks.
[LAUGHTER]
Our trip wasn't
exactly a vacation.
It was a wonderfully enjoyable,
but incredibly difficult
adventure, full of highs
and lows, exhilaration
and frustration.
Each week, many obstacles
forced us to live and operate
outside of our comfort zone.
An abbreviated list
of these obstacles
might include saddle
sores, tingling fingers,
and neck aches from
sitting on a bike 10 hours
a day, day, after
day, after day.
It would include flat
tires, broken spokes,
and other mechanical issues.
It would include visa
logistics, the fear
of financial irresponsibility,
and rationalizing our decision
to postpone parenthood.
Add to that poor
road quality, cycling
in the rain, oppressive heat,
and mountains beyond mountains.
Plus a possible
malaria infection,
and oncoming cows in India.
And the list really is endless.
In 280 days, we slept
in 169 different places.
Most of those places had
beds, but not all of them.
From the moment
we reached France,
until we landed on American
soil, almost nine months later,
we really didn't know how
to talk to most people,
because we only
really speak English.
Our communication was
done by smiling, pointing,
and counting on our fingers.
In the Alps it rained
for a week straight.
Instead of staying inside
waiting for the rain
to blow over, and instead of
putting on my new Patagonia
rain jacket, I decided
to cycle in nothing
more than socks,
shoes, and Spandex.
Because I quickly
learned that skin
dries out faster than clothing.
And once you're completely wet,
and you can't get any wetter,
cycling in the rain
really isn't that bad,
and maybe even enjoyable.
Cycling across the world forced
us out of our comfort zone.
The way we responded to
these difficult situations,
once outside our
comfort zone, dictated
how our day, and our week, and
our trip ultimately would go.
Today we're going to
tell a few stories that
highlight this point.
And, if by some strange chance,
by the end of our talk someone
is deciding to turn in
their resignation at Google,
I will consider
our talk a success.
[LAUGHTER]
Just kidding, keep your jobs.
KATY PRATT: Plus,
we can't say that.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So, before our trip my
life was very structured.
I rode the same bus to work,
I came to the same office,
I sat at the same desk,
I had breakfast and lunch
in the same cafe-- on
floor five that all of you
have lunch and breakfast on.
I would go home
to the same house,
and sleep in the
same bed every night.
Now, my routine was comfortable.
And I was good at it.
I liked it.
But biking across the world,
our routine definitely changed.
So, early on, I tried to
apply my desire for routine
and structure to our trip.
Every morning I wanted to know,
how far are we going to bike?
Is the road going to be flat?
Is it going to be hilly?
Are we going to encounter wind?
Are we going to encounter rain?
I need to know these things.
So, have we found a place
to stay every night?
And will I have a
place to shower?
I like showering.
Sticky, sweaty, legs at the
end of the day in your sleeping
bag, or in a bed,
are not, not fun.
So the answer to a
lot of these problems
was solved by Google
Maps bicycling directions
and weather apps.
So I looked at Google Maps
a lot in England and France.
But once we got to Italy,
Google Maps bicycling directions
failed.
They totally didn't exist.
So I didn't know what to do.
My whole idea of planning,
and being mentally prepared
each day, changed.
In Austria, someone told
us about another website
that we can use, so I
tried that for a while,
but in Albania
everything failed.
The second largest highway
in the whole country
turned out to be
a washed out road,
that we just rode down in, and
rode through puddles and mud.
And it got worse
as we went east.
In India, cities that
exist on Google Maps
didn't always appear
in the same places.
Or places that were
supposed to have towns
weren't always towns.
So at some point on our trip
we stopped checking maps
and weather, knowing
the elevation,
booking or looking
for a place to stay.
You kind of get to a state of
knowing whatever happens today,
we can do.
But it wasn't an
immediate switch.
It took being OK with not being
able to control everything,
and being OK with that.
And then some awesome
experiences happen.
So the first one I want to talk
to you about is wild camping.
So this is exactly
what it sounds
like, you camp in the wild.
As in, you stop on
the side of the road,
and just pitch your tent.
So this was totally
foreign to me,
and my rule-following self
had a hard time with this,
because it's illegal
in some places.
But you have to do it at times,
because hotels, or locals
to befriend don't exist.
So knew this was going to be
a thing going into our trip.
But before we got better
the wild camping process,
we were bad at it.
One specific time, we
were looking for a place.
It was after dark, which
was our first mistake.
We're down a dirt road.
We're like, this
place looks good,
although we can't see
anything, because it's dark.
So we're about to
get off the bike when
we hear a pack of wild dogs
start barking and running
towards us.
So, clearly, not a good
place to wild camp.
So I made us pack up and
backtrack to the last town.
Now, as we got
better at this, we
had one wild camping experience
on the Po River, where we--
CLAYTON PRATT: In Italy.
KATY PRATT: In Italy, where
we found a perfect spot.
We found a place with water.
This was going to be great.
So we set up our camp.
We were doing everything
we should be doing,
and it was going to
be a great night.
The moon was out, the
river was beautiful,
there weren't too
many mosquitoes.
But then some local
teenagers decided
our spot was pretty great, too.
So they joined us.
So all night we
listened to techno music
on the side of the river.
[LAUGHTER]
So, again, being outside
of your comfort zone.
And although we didn't have
the best sleep that night,
it was OK.
And it seemed to work out.
So we definitely got
better at wild camping.
Now the last kind
of experience I
wanted to talk to you
about, with the unknown,
it was in Thailand.
So we went from
Laos to Thailand.
And Laos is a kind of third
world communist country
that has more dirt roads,
things were more primitive.
But in Thailand, things
are much more westernized.
Lots of paved roads.
So we got to Thailand,
and Clayton got nervous.
Our dirt road adventures
were going to end.
What are we going to do?
So our day, going
from town A to town B,
he thought, maybe we shouldn't
take the direct route.
I think there's a pretty
good road this way.
I think we should go this way.
And I thought, OK,
we'll get there.
Why not?
So we followed what we
thought was this road.
Which turned into a dirt road.
Which turned out to
be pretty washed out.
We crossed multiple rivers.
It turns out we had to climb
three mountains on a dirt road
the size of maybe
two of our tandems,
and actually push it
over these mountains.
And we're talking, like,
push, as in like this,
up and over these mountains.
It was hard.
It was not in our
route, but it was fun.
And being OK outside
of our comfort zone
made me and Clayton OK with
this kind of experience,
which is why it was enjoyable.
CLAYTON PRATT: I would like to
talk about bike maintenance.
[LAUGHTER]
The thought of keeping this
loaded tandem up and running
for multiple countries and
thousands of kilometers
started out as a
pretty daunting ask.
Questions I had were, what if in
Serbia we get four flat tires?
What do we do?
What if in Turkey we get
in an accident and the rim
on our front wheel
bends a little bit?
What do we do?
What if we break a chain while
we're climbing in the Alps?
There were a lot of
things that I didn't know.
Before leaving, I
said, Katy, how many
spare spokes do you think we
should bring for our trip?
To which she said, are we
going to break any spokes?
And I said, I don't know.
There were a lot
of I don't knows,
and there was a seemingly
endless list of things
that could go wrong.
The easy solution is just
take it to a bike shop,
they'll fix it.
From the best of my
research, I discovered
that east of, maybe, Austria,
everything was up for grabs.
Eastern Europe, you might
be able to find a bike shop.
There was one really good
touring bike shop in Istanbul.
Everything between Istanbul and
Bangkok, don't expect anything.
So I kind of had the idea that
we needed to bring everything
that we needed.
If we did find a
bike shop in one
of these small, rural,
third world countries,
it was likely that the repair
equipment that they had
would not work for our bicycle.
In the West, most wheels are
700 millimeters in diameter,
and in the developing
world, all bicycles
have 26 inch wheels, similar
to our mountain bikes.
So if we found anything there,
tubes, tires, spokes, none
of them might be the right size.
With this sort of
nervous energy,
the following
happened on our trip.
In Northeastern
Slovenia, I started
to hear a weird clunking sound.
I'm a little bit anal, and a
clunking sound isn't so bad.
A little rubbing isn't bad.
But a little bit of rubbing
for 8,000 kilometers
is just going to completely
destroy whatever's rubbing.
So I started worrying.
The sound intensified
somewhere in Austria.
Katy started hearing it, too.
And it was strange.
The clucking sound came,
not when we were pedaling,
but when we stopped pedaling.
Usually you hear sounds
when you're pedaling.
That's when the
chains are moving.
That's when pedals are moving.
But this sound kind of came
right when we stopped pedaling.
And I didn't really
know what was going on.
We stayed with a
Warm Shower host--
which we'll talk about
in a bit-- in Vienna.
And this person, who had done
lots of previous touring,
suggested the problem might
be due to a new rear cassette
that we got to climb
mountains easier.
And it might have
to do something
with the length of our chain.
So I tried some adjustments,
took a couple links out
of our chain.
And the problem came back.
By the time we got to
Budapest, the problem
was pretty constant, and
I was kind of in denial.
Thinking, I don't
know what's going on.
There's some weird
noise back there.
I'd always ask Katy if
she knew what's going on.
She had no idea what's going on.
KATY PRATT: I'm not
a bike mechanic.
That was his job.
CLAYTON PRATT: I'm trying
to listen through Katy,
and all of these bags.
We got to a bike
shop in Budapest,
just as it was closing, and
they said come back in on Monday
morning.
And Katie and I
were like, no, we
don't want to give
up a whole weekend.
So we pushed on.
They told us to go to a town
in southern Hungary called
[INAUDIBLE].
Luckily, three
days later I found
someone who speaks
English to translate
my problems to our bike
mechanic, who actually
was a very good bike mechanic,
and only charged us $2 or $3.
And he said the
problem with our bike
was that inside the rear hub
there is a free wheel coasting
mechanism, which allows
the wheel to roll,
and the pedals to not move,
and let your bike coast.
He said there was
a bunch of grease
in there for an unknown reason.
And he showed me some
pictures, it had kind of
been chewed up a little bit.
But he cleaned it out,
threw some oil in there.
I wasn't exactly convinced,
but the next day our bike
was perfect.
It worked great.
Serbia, Croatia, Bosnia,
Macedonia, everything
was going good.
And then we got to Albania,
and we're descending a mountain
just south of Tirana.
And out of nowhere-- we're
going 40 miles an hour--
this just screaming,
crashing, clunking,
awful sound just comes
right out of our rear wheel.
And I know instantly that
that problem is back,
and it is much
worse than it was.
Slammed on the brakes,
Katy and I both get off,
I throw the bike on the ground,
probably say a few swear words.
Katy picks the bike back up.
And I'm thinking, all right,
the town's down there,
we can see it in the
distance, we'll walk there.
We couldn't even
walk the bicycle,
because the wheel could not roll
if the pedals were not moving.
So we said, all right,
we'll just pedal downhill.
So we got on the bike,
shifted into the hardest gear,
and we pedaled all
the way downhill.
And after a while, I'm
thinking, this is ridiculous.
If this hub is ruined,
let's just ruin it.
So I stopped pedaling.
But the sound didn't show up.
And I'm thinking, all right, now
we have bicycle that's broken,
only when it wants to be.
The next day, in Elbasan,
I thought, all right,
wheel's ruined.
What should we do?
We get on the bike that
morning, totally fine.
So now it's like, all right,
bike's got a mind of it's own.
We're just going to continue.
If disaster strikes,
disaster strikes.
That was in Albania.
We got to Macedonia, there
were some more problems.
We went to another
bike mechanic,
I told him what the
other bike mechanic did,
he did the exact same thing.
Pull out some grease,
put in some lubricant.
And that got us a
couple more days.
But by the time we got
to Thessaloniki, Greece,
it was nonstop pedaling,
never allowed to coast,
bumper to bumper traffic,
pretty miserable cycling.
We were a week out from
Istanbul, and we're like,
all right, Greece,
developed country,
we're going to find
a real bike mechanic,
we're getting this fixed.
Luckily, we find a bike mechanic
right next to our hostel.
And we go in there, he says,
no, no, no, no, this other thing
is your problem.
Fix this.
And we're like, all
right, whatever.
The next morning, we're climbing
up this really steep hill,
and we've just gone down the
other side of this steep hill.
Problem comes back.
And we're like, you've
got to be kidding me.
Hitchhike back to Greece,
back to Thessaloniki.
Tell him the problem.
He decides to try to
fix the other problem.
And then, to make
sure it's fixed,
and because it kind of
has a mind of its own,
I go cycling up and down the
coast for two hours, trying
to elicit this problem,
because I don't want
to leave if it's still broken.
It's fine.
Go up the hill, coming
back down the other side,
problem comes back.
And it's just-- Katy
and I, we sit down
on this side of the
highway, 30 meters apart,
bicycle in the middle,
don't talk to each other.
And then there was kind of
this, like, aha moment of,
our wheel is definitely broken.
And all of our worrying about
it definitely being broken.
Is it going to work, is
it not going to work?
All of that disappeared.
And all of the sudden
we got over that hurdle,
and it was like,
our wheel is broken.
And so Katy said, so,
should we hitchhike?
Katy's a pretty good hitchhiker.
KATY PRATT: It's
a skill I learned.
CLAYTON PRATT: Istanbul
was a week away,
and I wasn't just
going to say, our wheel
has problems, let's hitchhike.
So I said, we're
going to cycle there.
And if we destroy our
wheel, we destroy our wheel.
So for seven straight days we
cycled all the way to Istanbul,
into a headwind,
never able to coast.
It was pretty miserable.
Oh, one thing I need to add.
When the wheel totally
went kaput, I got online,
and I ordered a new
hub from the States,
to be shipped to
a Warm Shower host
that we would be staying with,
similar to couch surfing,
in Istanbul.
We cycle our seven days,
we get to Istanbul,
we go to our Warm
Shower host's home.
The hub doesn't show up.
It's stuck in customs.
It's stuck there for a week.
We finally get it out,
thanks to the help of someone
that we were staying
with at the time.
Take it to a bike shop, he
says, great, I'll fix it.
Katy and I get on a bus
and we go to central Turkey
to site see.
Get an email from
the guy, and he says,
sorry, your rear hub lacks an
attachment for a disk rotor.
If you put this on, you
won't have a rear brake
for the rest of your trip.
And I'm like stabbing
myself in the face.
Like, you have got
to be kidding me.
How many problems can go wrong?
Call up the guy in
the states, say, hey,
will you send this attachment?
We'd like to have two brakes.
But knowing that customs
is a huge problem, I think,
we need a backup plan.
So I order another
one, and send it
to my sister, who's coming to
meet us in Nepal a month later.
We get back to Istanbul,
the part never arrives.
We go to Israel for a week.
We come back, it
still never arrives.
We leave Istanbul
six weeks later,
and the only thing on our to-do
list, fix our rear wheel, still
had not happened.
We arrived in Nepal, my
sister gives us the new hub,
I get on Google, and I
look at every single bike
shop in Kathmandu.
And per Google, I found the
best one, Himalayan Singletrack.
[LAUGHTER]
I take my hub and my wheel.
We're basically turning
over the rest of our trip.
I take it to this Nepali, who
speaks a little bit of English,
and I said, can you
rebuild this wheel?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you sure?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I was like, all right.
What other options do we have?
Katy and I, and my
sister, my mother,
we go off trekking in
the Himalayas for a week.
We come back, early
in the morning,
and I'm walking up to
the bike shop by myself,
and I'm just terrified.
Is our trip going to continue?
I walked into the shop,
and in the corner,
on an unswept dirty
floor, is a pile
of spokes, a hub, and my rim.
And I'm thinking, you've
got to be kidding me.
We don't have a
bicycle that works.
I said, what's going on?
You haven't done anything?
He says, well, this
problem, this--
No, no, no.
The spokes are the right size.
The hub's the right size.
It's all right.
You said you can do this.
I'm coming back in an hour
to see if you've started.
Come back in an hour,
there's nobody in the store.
And I'm thinking--
KATY PRATT: Things run
a little differently.
CLAYTON PRATT: I'm
thinking, all right,
either our trip ends, or I find
out how to rebuild a wheel.
Because that was where we were.
Professional bike
mechanics, when
they want to build a wheel,
they use truing stands,
and calibrated
instruments that help
you measure the
tension on your spokes,
to make sure that
everything is correct.
I did not have any
of these things.
In my guest house
in Kathmandu, I
had a cheap multitool,
a piece of fabric ruler,
and was one of those floss
picks to use as a straight edge.
And that is what I used
to rebuild our wheel.
Instead of using a
tension meter to find out
if the spokes were tight
enough, I plucked the spokes
like guitar strings, to see
how much tension there was.
Because one side
of the wheel was
supposed to be tighter than the
other side, based on which side
the chain is on.
I went back to the
bike shop, and I
plucked all of the spokes
of the industry-made bikes,
to see if that tension matched
the tension on my wheel.
I watched a lot of YouTube
videos, I read a lot of blogs.
And I was on a little
bit of a time frame
crunch, because my sister
was leaving 18 hours later.
And so I had that night
to rebuild our wheel,
or send our bicycle home,
because our bike didn't work.
The only thing
that kind of scared
me was that I didn't just need
to build a decent wheel, that
could just roll down
a normal paved road.
We were heading into
Nepal, and India,
with potholes galore, bad roads.
We were carrying 400, 500 pounds
on our bike, and all of this
is resting on our rear wheel.
So I had to do a pretty damn
good job if our trip was
going to continue.
But it all worked out.
When I was put up
against the wall,
with no other options left, six
bike mechanics had failed me,
a problem for the last
three months, everything
that everybody had
tried had failed,
I'd done everything
I possibly could.
When pushed right
up against that wall
I was able to figure it out.
And that night I
rebuilt our wheel,
and we cycled through all of
India without a broken spoke,
of and without having
to re-true our wheel.
When we get outside
of our comfort zone,
either because we choose
to-- or in my case,
because we are
forced to-- we can
begin to realize what
our potential is,
and what we are capable of.
I learned more
about wheel building
and about fixing
problems that night,
than I would have in
the next 50 years.
I would have just taken
it to a bike shop.
This rear wheel was the
biggest nuisance of our trip,
but I couldn't be
happier with the outcome.
I solved a problem that we
both thought was impossible,
and our trip was
able to continue.
KATY PRATT: It's true, he
did do a really good job.
And I was very little help.
I ran for tools,
down the street.
So the last part I
want to talk about,
with getting outside
of our comfort zone,
is something called
Warm Showers.
Clayton mentioned this briefly.
So warmshowers.org is
not just a warm shower.
It's a website similar
to couch surfing.
A reciprocal kind of
hosting site, where
anyone can become a member.
You go online, and then you look
at this map, and you see hosts,
and you email them
for a place to stay.
Now, Warm Showers is
specific to bike touring.
So often, people who are hosts
are bike tourers themselves,
and have used the site
on their own tour.
And the norm of Warm Showers,
unlike couch surfing,
is the host provides you
with dinner, breakfast,
and a free place to stay.
So this is a pretty big
deal for bike tourers.
And then you learn about all
the various roads to go on,
and all the details of
the local area you are in.
Now why would Warm
Showers be problematic?
When I was growing up, my
family went on vacations,
we stayed at hotels, we
did adventurous things.
But we didn't stay
at strangers' houses.
My parents taught me, like all
of you, to be self-sufficient.
I was a professional who'd had
a job at Google for three years.
Surely I could afford
a place to stay.
But night after night for a
year was stretching our budget.
So Warm Showers meant relying
on the kindness of strangers,
which felt very foreign.
Now there are the normal
concerns you have.
Cleanliness, going into
someone else's house,
do they have the same standard
of cleanliness as you do?
You can't really tell
from a picture or a blurb.
Safety, going into
a stranger's home,
we don't know who
they actually are.
The awkwardness of trying
to talk to a stranger.
Not everyone's a very
good conversationalist.
Before our first Warm
Shower experience,
I casually asked Clayton,
what if they kill us?
[LAUGHTER]
And he turned to me and said,
well, what if we kill them?
Which was a valid point.
However, it never
got to this point,
and we never actually worried.
So I definitely
recommend Warm Showers.
We originally kind of did this
with the intent of, oh, this
will help our trip last longer,
we'll meet these people.
But really, Warm Showers
was so much more,
and such a crucial
part of our trip.
I'm going to share a few
stories, or just a few people
that we've met along the
way, through Warm Showers.
So the first is
in Eastern France.
I don't know, you can
kind of see from that,
over there, Clayton.
Monsieur and Madame Bertier.
They spoke no English, and
we spoke very little French.
Clayton took classes
in junior high school.
Their son signed up for Warm
Showers, and he wasn't home,
but he said, my
parents will host you.
We had a picturesque
evening on a farm in France,
and ended up having the
best dessert of our trip.
Lots of signs, and
smiling, and since they
lived on a farm, lots
of farm animal noises,
which we became very good at.
They also led us into the whole
aspect of a cheese course.
The French really do have a
whole section of their meal
related to cheese.
And we've got to try so
many amazing cheeses.
Now the next one is
Bashar, in Istanbul.
Clayton mentioned him.
He was the Warm Shower
host who helped us out
with our bike hub.
We were able to ship
the part to his house.
He helped us with customs.
He helped us figure out
who to pay and when to pay.
And how to actually get a
part out of customs in Turkey.
He let us stay in his
house for what ended up
being two weeks,
which was significant,
because he had a
flat in the city,
and he stayed at his house
two hours outside of the city.
So one way, twice a day, he was
commuting to his other home,
because he wanted to
show us hospitality,
and let us stay at his house.
Now, when our bike
part was not there.
Sorry, I keep
dropping-- thank you.
He let us keep our
luggage at his house,
all the while showing us local
sites, local restaurants,
and local foods.
Now another one is [INAUDIBLE]
and Alesh in Slovenia.
They stopped us on
the side of the road,
because we were riding a
tandem, and they ride a tandem.
And they invited us
over to their house.
They said, you absolutely
have to come stay with us.
Now what's unique about
[INAUDIBLE] and Alesh
is Alesh is blind,
and he sits on back.
And [INAUDIBLE]
sits in the front.
He was so intrigued
to see another tandem,
he ran his hands over all
the parts and components,
and asked so many questions.
The last one is Rene in Laos.
He's a German ex-pat
living there doing
microlending for the
surrounding 135 villages.
He up and moved to Laos
knowing zero language, just
to make a difference,
and thought
it would be a great experience.
Now lots of people
might think he's
a little crazy for
wanting to do this,
but he was making a difference,
and had such a positive outlook
on life.
He took us trekking
in the jungle,
swimming at the
local swimming hole.
He took us to the
sauna, which is
how he met and became
friends with, and learned
how to speak in the language.
He was outside of
his comfort zone.
Now we were lucky enough
to meet people on our trip,
and lucky enough to be
able to have the experience
to interact with them.
Now you don't necessarily
have to go across the world
and use Warm Showers
to be able to meet
interesting and new people.
You have to be open to it.
Whether it's smiling at
people in the grocery
store, or saying hi to
people on the street.
Even here at Google,
I think, oh my gosh,
there are other people on
floors that I don't know,
that I don't even
necessarily say hi to.
So it's just being
open to new people,
and being open to being
outside of your comfort zone,
that you can really have
an impactful difference
in your life, and people can
make a difference in your life.
That's one thing that's
really important.
CLAYTON PRATT: In closing,
briefly, much of our life
is routine.
We are creatures of
habit and comfort,
and we repeatedly do what
we are used to doing.
That's not always bad,
but it doesn't always
have to be like that.
Yes, Katy and I were
fortunate enough
to be able to go on a once
in a lifetime journey.
However, the journey is
over, and it is our hope
that we have learned
things that we
will be able to do and remember
for the rest of our lives.
We discovered how much fun
it is to meet new people.
To talk to people that we
didn't know when we woke up
that morning, especially people
who are very different from us.
We learned how to deal with the
unknown, and to be OK with it.
To accept difficulty,
and hardship,
and in change in routines,
and know that in the end,
everything will work out.
We learned that
sometimes, if we step
outside of the routine and
confines of comfort, then
we're able to accomplish goals
and dreams that we previously
thought were not possible.
We are going to open this up
to questions, after we show
some photos of our friends.
KATY PRATT: Unless, do you want
to do questions first, Mark?
OK, any questions for us?
CLAYTON PRATT: From the back.
KATY PRATT: One sec, we'll
just get a microphone.
Sure.
CLAYTON PRATT: Sure.
AUDIENCE: You guys
are so awesome.
KATY PRATT: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Was there a period of training
in preparation for the trip?
Are you guys avid bicyclists?
How did this all happen?
Were you always comfortable
with these crazy days
of miles and miles of bicycling?
CLAYTON PRATT: Katy got
appendicitis six weeks
before we left, and her
training was sub-par.
[LAUGHTER]
KATY PRATT:
According to Clayton.
So we are both cyclists, but we
didn't do a crazy training plan
before hand.
A lot of bike tourers
say that you kind of
build up endurance
right at the beginning.
We were really exhausted at the
beginning, and kind of slowly
got our cycling legs.
CLAYTON PRATT: I told Katy that
she needed to be able to cycle
100 miles within seven
hours before we left.
She got pretty close.
After two weeks, you're
just in good shape.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you guys so much,
this is actually very
similar to something I
want to do while I'm in my 20s.
KATY PRATT: Good for you.
AUDIENCE: And I came
in a few minutes late,
so I apologize if you
covered this already.
But over the
conversations you guys
had with your friends,
managers, very close people
right before leading up
to this trip, [INAUDIBLE]?
KATY PRATT: So,
first, Clayton thought
it would be a good idea if we
didn't tell any of our family,
and we just sent
them post cards,
which was not going to happen.
But at first, we actually
didn't tell everyone right
at the beginning,
just because we
didn't want to be
the people that
almost went on a bike trip.
So we actually started working
on things, to see like, OK,
could we make us happen, before
we then told our families.
And we told our families
on New Year's Eve.
We were trying to get them
to ask us what our New Year's
resolutions were.
And then Clayton went off
with this, this is our plan.
And they thought we were joking.
And we weren't.
So that's kind of
how we started.
CLAYTON PRATT: There were really
just two big logistical things,
would Michigan let
me leave for a year?
So I just sat down
with my counselor,
and she said, take one
year of personal leave.
And I said, sure.
And then Katy talked to
Google, and having a job
held for greater than six
months proved to be difficult.
But she was told, re-apply
when you come back.
It kind of came down
to-- the conversation
that we had amongst
ourselves was, we're young,
we're in good shape, we
don't have a child yet.
One's on the way now.
[APPLAUSE]
We kind of said, if
this doesn't happen now,
then it might
happen in 30 years.
But it's either we do
this in six months,
or we talk about
it for 30 years.
So we kind of just jumped on
it, and everything kind of
fell into place.
AUDIENCE: Well, congratulations.
[LAUGHTER]
KATY PRATT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about safety on the bike?
I saw one photo, and I
didn't see any helmets.
So maybe some war
stores, or [INAUDIBLE]?
[LAUGHTER]
KATY PRATT: Good question.
CLAYTON PRATT: When we
got to Leeds, England,
third night of our trip,
I took off my helmet
and buckled it to the
back of our bicycle,
and I never put it on again.
KATY PRATT: I wore
mine much longer.
[LAUGHTER]
CLAYTON PRATT: Katy
wore hers longer.
What we found was
that cycling was
scary in one type of country.
In first world
countries, cycling
is a recreational activity,
and there's bike lanes,
and people are used to
cyclists on the road.
That was fine.
In third world countries
people are still
riding bicycles because
that's how they get around.
And so we were just one of many.
We thought India
would be the scariest.
And although there was a
lot going on on the road,
and we had to pay
much attention,
the fear of being hit by a
semi going 70 miles an hour
never happened,
because nobody in India
can go 70 miles an hour.
There's just too much
other stuff on the road.
Where things were a little
bit dangerous, kind of scary,
where Katy and I thought,
we've got to get off this road,
I would say it would be
like, Serbia, Hungary,
maybe the second
world, Eastern Europe.
Because people are starting
to get driver's licenses,
and they have to
have good roads,
and they're driving
really, really fast,
and nobody in those
countries rides bicycles.
As far as accidents,
we had zero.
We tipped over, I would
say, somewhere in England,
when we were on a
very, very small road,
going about three miles an hour.
And this car pulled up
like right next to us,
and I kind of braced us.
But then the car went
past, and we tipped over.
KATY PRATT: This was the
first time I dropped my phone.
It subsequently broke
on the whole trip.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so the
bike itself is probably
worth thousands,
and you probably
had thousands of dollars
worth of gear on the bike.
Is that something you
had to worry about,
as you're traveling
around, like at night?
Just leaving it outside the
tent, or going to restaurants,
having that out there?
Because I'm sure it stuck
out like a sore thumb,
in some locations.
Was that a concern?
KATY PRATT: It definitely
was, and I think, at first,
when it was shiny, shiny,
new, it was a bigger concern.
Now it's kind of banged up
a little bit, which is good.
At the beginning we started
hanging our dirty laundry
on it, like, oh, no one
will even come near it,
if our dirty laundry is on it.
But yeah, that was a concern.
We did have a bike lock, to
attach it to things, as well
as the front wheel.
But, kind of slowly,
as our trip went on,
we just kind of kept
the bike around us.
I mean, obviously, if
it had been stolen,
it would have been
a pretty big issue.
So we were very careful and
aware of it, but it was never--
Most nights we brought
the bicycle inside.
If a hostel said, you
can't bring your bike in,
we just said, all right, we're
going to a different hostel.
The fear of it being
stolen, I would say,
would be the greatest in
urban Western Europe cities,
where there was some
sort of resale value.
As soon as we got
east of Turkey,
no one was going to steal
it, because there was nothing
they could do with it.
If a little kid in
Laos steals our bike,
everybody knows it's not his.
KATY PRATT: There was
only one red double cycle.
Which is how everyone said,
double cycle, double cycle.
CLAYTON PRATT: The
interesting story
is that in India,
sometimes you wouldn't
be able to bring
it up to your room,
but you could put
it in the lobby.
And for weeks, Katy
and I would wake up
at like 5 in the
morning, and we'd
hear people playing
with our bell.
And it was reassuring, because
our bike was still there.
But it was like, great, you're
playing with our bicycle.
There was kind of this, what's
ours is yours mentality.
And then we'd go
down in the morning,
and they'd show us
pictures of, like, they'd
been riding our bike
around, taking pictures.
And it's like, it still works.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, so is there
some sort of synchronization
for riding a tandem bike?
And, also, as a follow
up to that, did you
guys ever switch orders?
KATY PRATT: So, synchronization.
There's what's called
a timing chain.
They do make tandems
that are not in sync,
but ours is in sync.
So we did have to pedal in sync
if our pedals were synchronized
on the timing chain.
We tried it being out of sync,
but it was a little weird.
So when we bought our tandem, at
the tandem shop, here in town,
he asked us, have you ever
ridden a tandem before?
And we actually had, this
is our second tandem.
He said, I will not let people
buy tandems if they've never
ridden a tandem.
Because people think
it's like a great idea,
to go on a tandem bike.
Oh, it sounds so romantic.
But it's actually very hard.
And, I mean, its
great being together,
you arrive at the
same time, but there
are lots of cons with
riding a tandem, too.
So, we were in sync.
CLAYTON PRATT: If one
of us is pedaling,
the other person
has to be pedaling.
So the biggest
arguments were over
cadence-- how fast to pedal.
KATY PRATT: Or if we
were actually pedaling.
CLAYTON PRATT: How hard
of a gear to be in.
KATY PRATT: And then to
answer your second question,
Clayton mostly rode in front.
Mostly-- always.
[LAUGHTER]
CLAYTON PRATT: There was one
day, where we were in Utah,
we had just kind of gotten
through some sandy roads,
and it became too hard to cycle
with both of us on the bike,
so one of us would cycle
while the other one would run.
KATY PRATT: Along side.
CLAYTON PRATT: One
night, I did the cycling,
and Katy did the running.
In the morning, Katy did the
cycling, I did the running.
When we finally got to a paved
road, I hopped on the back,
and I was there
for about an hour.
KATY PRATT: He
couldn't handle it.
So the front is
actually really hard,
because you have-- I mean,
those front two bags.
Right now they're pretty light,
they just have clothes in them.
But they had sizable
amounts of weight on them.
So turning the tandem and
maneuvering the tandem
is actually very
difficult and heavy.
Plus, he really likes
the chaos, and being
on the front of the bike.
And I actually love
being on the back.
I saw so much more than he
ever saw on our whole trip.
We'd get somewhere, and I'd be
like, did you see x, y, and z?
He was like, what are
you talking about?
I saw pothole, pothole, pothole,
white line, yellow line.
So it was actually great.
FACILITATOR: All right.
CLAYTON PRATT: Slide show?
FACILITATOR: So
maybe what we'll do
is wrap up the Q&A and this
part of the presentation.
And then for those
that can stay,
there's a slide show, here.
And we'll just enjoy
the slide show,
and thank Katy and Clayton
for being here today.
Give them a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
KATY PRATT: Thank
you, good audience.